over the course of roughly two dozen
games the hero of Hyrule has thought the
evil picked based Ganon rescued various
princesses and kept them the serious
Triforce out of enemy hands that's all
well and good it's just a shame that
link causes so much trouble along the
way it's really not okay to break every
thought you see dude
whether skyward bound adrift in time or
steep in Twilight the various
incarnations of Link have saved Hyrule
countless times over the Legend of Zelda
series unfortunately that doesn't mean
the beloved hero hasn't done his fair
share of creepy stuff along the way what
kind of stuff
well ghosts creep given that he doesn't
say much it's easy to assume that link
is a humble selfless hero but according
to Hyrule historia the official guide to
the Legend of Zelda series that's not
entirely true
after the events of the Ocarina of Time
and Majora's Mask our hero is so furious
that he's not remembered for his
accomplishments that he sticks around
for hundreds of years as a ghost unable
to let go in Twilight Princess
he actually haunts the younger Link one
of the hero of times many descendants
and it's not just like he takes the form
of a grumpy old man he stalks Ling
Junior as a glowing wolf and terrifying
skeleton called hero shade it actually
ends up working out pretty well for
young link since the skeleton teaches
link advanced sword fighting techniques
but introducing yourself via wolf attack
at a one-punch knock down just to prove
you're hot stuff is unbecoming of any
link living or dead chicken smacking
when wandering poultry first appeared in
a Link to the Past they didn't do much
but hop around and cluck leaving players
to wonder what exactly they were good
for the answer is well pretty much
nothing unless you like whacking farm
animals with the sword hi Rose poultry
have been hit so often they've had to
organize to stay safe smack Ikuko too
many times a little summon is friends
who swarm link from all directions and
peck him to death this isn't a one-time
thing either attackable and vengeful
cuccos have appeared in almost every
Zelda game from a Link to the Past all
the way through breadth of the wild so
this begs the question who's worse the
guy who programs in birds you can injure
or the player that actively injures bird
some things never change and link
abusing animals is one of them grave
robbing in Hyrule goodies are stashed
everywhere in pots under bridges in
chests and then the guts of every
monster you kill and just like in the
real world
some of Hyrule treasures are buried with
their owners but when links on a quest
not even basic morality will stand
between him and looting some corpses in
the original Legend of Zelda second
quest Lincoln covers a dungeon entrance
by pushing aside a gravestone in a Link
to the Past knocking a gravestone and
climbing into the tomb below Nets link
at Cape with invisibility powers look if
great grandpa wants to be buried in his
invisibility cape who's going to say no
links worst defense however occurs in
ocarina of time where the young
adventurer doesn't even bother to do the
grave robbing himself when link visits
Kakariko graveyard he can fork over 10
rupees to make the local gravedigger dig
a hole or ever link one uncovering
anything from a few bucks to an entire
heart container
even if you call it da peas heart
pounding grave digging tour it's still
ghoulish you may find a treasure but you
may also find aunt Bertha's jawbone and
a lifetime of nightmares fortunately for
Link's treasure hoard respect to the
dead isn't an issue
he destroyed an island for nothing in
Link's Awakening our hero link washes up
on : island after his ship is wrecked
during a storm
naturally link begins looking for a way
home by killing everything in sight and
learns he can escape : by waking up the
wind fish a slumbering monster at the
heart of the island but there's a catch
: is the product of the wind fish's
dream and waking him will destroy the
island and all of its inhabitants that's
exactly what link does the island and
all of its inhabitants vanish and Link
wakes up in the middle of the ocean
clinging to a piece of driftwood this is
a just fan speculation either the Hyrule
historia calls his choice to destroy : a
bitter decision all that and Link
doesn't even get back to Hyrule that
particular version of Link sets sail
after his adventure but his further
whereabouts are unknown
meaning that link effectively destroyed
an island for absolutely no reason
harassing Zelda while video game link is
almost entirely nonverbal cartoon link
was an entirely different kind of hero
there is no good explanation for why the
writers of the 1989 Legend of Zelda
animated series turn link from noble
hero into a wisecracking brat who's
constantly saved by the princess
if cartoon link had just been a whiner
it would be bad enough but he was mainly
after getting the girl more so than
anything else from the very first
episode he Ogle's Zelda wherever she's
getting dressed cat calls her looking
good princess especially from this angle
and tries to kiss Zelda when she isn't
expecting it that all happens in the
first six minutes and it doesn't get
better over the course of the show's 13
episode run link spends almost all of
his time trying to score whether it's
with Zelda or with weird anonymous
witches dying
yesmy combined links unseemly behavior
with his general y ninis and you're left
hoping again and wins
speaking of Link's weird perversions the
Hyrule streaker links unusual behavior
didn't end in the 80s in breadth of the
wild blink roams the freeform open-world
game with very few limits want to ignore
the main quest and just spend your time
causing havoc among Hyrule's ruins go
right ahead
want to track down shrines and defeat
Ganon in your undies you can do that too
basically the game is so freeform that
link doesn't have to wear any other
clothes if you don't want him to and
that's more than enough to fin hylians
delicate sensibilities while some people
don't mind seeing links tighty-whities a
teenage girl who lives in Kakariko
village is absolutely traumatized by the
sight of links barely contained buns at
best making people uncomfortable like
that it's selfish and only profitable if
you live in New York City at worst it's
a crime and one that should be punished
preferably with death by chickens thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you